ate it in Europe and both countries
stretching between two major regions of
Europe the Baltic Sea region and the
Black Sea region are a kind of bridge
and link between these two major regions
in Europe both countries are playing a
very important role as a bridge between
the West's of Europe and Russia between
the west of Europe and Asia both
countries may be either the link between
these two major geopolitical realities
or an obstacle both are very important
strategic countries for the transit of
oil and gas supply to west of Europe
Central Europe from Russia and new basin
in Caspian both countries have
established the relationship of a
special kinda strategic relationship in
1997 and from my point of view the
strategic relationship between both
countries is the only real one Ukraine
has with other countries being referred
to as a strategic partners of Ukraine
like Russia the United States Azerbaijan
and Uzbekistan the strategic partnership
between our two countries is a real
asset not only for our people but for
our countries and for the whole of
Central and Eastern Europe and the
Europe as a whole Ukraine in Poland
in the perspective can play the similar
role france in germany used to play
together and four countries this four
countries can serve as an arc of
stability for the whole of Europe I
already has touched upon the issue of
the opening of the year of Poland in
Ukraine though the official opening is
to take place next week I would like to
say that at the NGO level this year has
started much earlier and I'm happy to
say that the Institute I am a director
of the Institute for Euro Atlantic
operation with together with the center
for international relations in in water
has organized and conducted the
conference which was the first
conference in this year two thousand
four devoted to the Ukraine Poland
strategic partnership relationship and
I'm happy that this conference was a
very good and visible for the NGO
community not only for the NGO
communities of both countries but to
both governments the major logo of this
year which is going to be proclaimed
this coming Tuesday will be Ukraine and
Poland together in Europe and I think
that this logo is having a very precise
precise emphasis on the role of both
countries are playing and are going to
play in Europe it is not a coincidence
that the year of Poland in Ukraine is
going to begin immediately after the
year of Russia has ended in Ukraine and
I do hope that this year the year of
Poland in Ukraine will be much more
positive and successful that the last
year 2003 being the year of Russia in
Ukraine I'm not going to dwell on this
issue feather on but to my mind this was
a complete failure I mean the year of
Russia in Ukraine during this proceeding
panel we had very interesting statements
of both panelists and I'm not going to
speak and to repeat on what was said but
I would like to say a few words about
how Poland and Ukraine are doing in
foreign policy